this video was made possible by news
voice a democratized news app created to
fight back against the filter bubbles
caused by corporate media download for
free from news voice dot-com / Pakman or
click the link under this video so this
next story unfortunately does fall
underneath the same category of it's a
feature and not a bug conservative
violence is being ignored by the police
now Gavin McInnes are making whatever
his name is Gavin making other proud
boys proud boys is they are the answer
to an Tifa on the left and Tifa
anti-fascists the people who are willing
to put their bodies on the line to fight
fascism the proud boys is the response
to that and they are they were started
and being promoted by a conservative
pundit who has a show on CR TV as well
as is a regular guest on Fox News Gavin
McInnes and his group had a meeting in
New York I don't know if David covered
this but it's about a week old they had
a meeting in New York over the weekend
and they after the meeting they beat it
was a 30 to 330 proud boys beat up of
three members of NT foe now you know if
that makes you proud I mean if that
makes you feel bad you know
okay 32 3 but where I come from one on
one anyway I digress I'm not here to
promote the violence I'm here to expose
the violence that NYPD has yet to really
do anything about it they were aware of
it at the time but did nothing about it
at the time now I did read one headline
I didn't get in-depth into the article
but I read that there may be some
arrests coming but the NYPD was aware of
it that night and we're almost a week
later and no one's been held accountable
for it yet we'll see what happens that
remains to be seen but Gavin McInnes our
McInnes or whatever however you
pronounce this guy's name has been given
a profile a flattering profile in the
New York Times and The New York Times
begins to explore who he is in his
motivations of where he came from and
maybe there's an attempt in there to
question him about his violent tactics
but but two things stand out about it
number one the Prabhu's are protecting
fascism
they are fascist they are they are
people who are carrying out and
implementing and protecting this power
structure in the United States that Bill
O'Reilly himself defined as white
Christian men you do what that as you
please this is who they are they are
literally a gang they are a gang and
whereas the federal government and state
governments have cracked down on every
quote-unquote gang that has any type of
minority membership they are doing
nothing about the proud boy gang a
matter of fact they're getting headlines
in the New York Times now if you think
I'm being hyperbolic if you think I'm
describing them as thugs and gangs and
I'm just kind of being exaggerating
don't take my word for it here's Gavin
himself
I started this gang called the proud
boys and out boys the proud boys what is
that what's proud boys about we have
chapters all over the world we get drunk
and just it's like the Elks Lodge okay
like Masons or whatever celebrating
manhood yeah no women allowed oh wow I
can't tell you woman what goes on to
meetings and we have different degrees
like the Knights of Columbus first
degree you declare yourself a broad boy
second degree we beat the [ __ ] out of
you until you can name five breakfast
cereals and yep masturbating and then
third degree you still have to give up
masturbating but you have to get a
tattoo and then fourth degree you get
arrested or in a serious violent fight
for the Greeley's yes so yeah they're
gang they're a gang that seeks to commit
violence that is their goal the goal of
ante foe whether you like them or not
whether you agree with them or not it is
to hold the line against fascism even
through the use of force
you can absolutely disagree with them
but you can also also realize that
the police regularly cracked down on
antifa
they search the FBI searches for it they
have coin tail Pro operations in order
to destabilize and Tifa the federal
government is focused on left-leaning
activism and violence in a way that they
will never freak focus on conservative
violence conservative violence get
profiles literal profiles I mean even go
back to the Richard Spencer Nazi profile
and Mother Jones you know that this is
the this is what conservatives get in
this country and this is not a shock
this is not a surprise this is sadly a
feature of the system y-you know when
you consider the number of white
supremacists who are actually working in
our enforcement agencies both on the
federal level as well as on the local
level and the state level when you
consider the number of white
supremacists who are intertwined in our
police state in general are our
intelligence state are you know why
would they why would they turn on their
brethren this is I'm not saying all of
them are this but enough of them are
we've seen instances where the police
agencies in this country have made
alliances have worked with white
nationalist organizations in order to
thwart left-leaning violence or to in
order to identify people who are
connected to left-wing violence and yet
here we are with a guy who literally
promotes himself as they gang Lord is a
leader of a gang who promotes the
violence expressly in no uncertain terms
he's being given a profile in The New
York Times he's been giving color did
the police are not messing with them
they don't they let him do what he wants
he's on Fox News with Tucker Carlson on
a regular basis he has his own show on
CR TV this is how America was designed
to work because I said all that to get
to this because
violence in America is a honored time
honored and respected tradition if you
are a white conservative male anger in
this country is was a respected and
relentless relentlessly utilize emotion
it is harnessed and unleashed for
political change if you're a white male
conservative male let's be clear right
if you are a conservative then you could
be as violent as you want to be violence
in the name of a conservative goal is
not considered a vice in this country
this is why people think it's Peter I
hate to keep going back to my theme song
but people try to point out the
hypocrisy of individuals conservatives
who like to champion they love the
Boston Tea Party but then they turn
around and say oh and Tifa are they're
destroying property so you know we point
out the hypocrisy but I what I'm trying
to help you understand is they know this
and they don't care because they feel
like the only people who have the right
to use violence in this country are
conservatives particularly conservative
men specifically conservative white men
because they are reflection of the power
structure in this country conservative
white men so of course if they will see
it as perfectly fine for them to use
violence but to look at left-leaning
violence or any type of violence that is
attacking this oppressive structure they
look at it as illegitimate is something
that has to be crushed it is not a bug
it is a feature it is by design this is
why a the leader of a gang can have a
show on CR TV can be a regular guest fox
news be profiled in the New York Times
and the police just say nothing as 30 of
his gang members beat up three people
from antiva